diana thank you very much and we're
going to go straight uh to the capital
of ukraine kiev where the u.n secretary
general is speaking i can expand support
for the people of ukraine
saving lives reducing suffering
and helping find the path of peace
i want ukrainian people to know that the
world sees you
hears you
and is in awe of your resilience and
resolve
i also know that words of solidarity are
not enough
i am here to zero in on needs on the
ground and scale up operations
let me be very clear
the security council failed to do
everything in its power to prevent and
end this war
and this is a source of great
disappointment frustration and anger
but the men and women of the united
nations are working every day for the
people of ukraine side by side with so
many brave ukrainian organizations
i salute the more than 1400 staff of the
u.n
the vast majority of whom are ukrainian
nationals
they are on the ground in nine
operational hubs and 30 locations
many have been here from day one and we
have sent in additional personnel since
then to serve the ukrainian people
they are engaged in an enormously
complicated mission and a difficult
conditions
this is one of the fastest scale up
operations we have ever undertaken
and we are very much aware that not
everything is perfect
whatever we can provide
pains in comparison to the needs
and i'm here to pledge that will boost
our efforts across the board
coordinating with ukrainian government
every step of the way
until now
we have provided life-saving
humanitarian aid to 3.4 million people
inside ukraine
and we are aiming to more than double
that number to 8.7 million by the end of
august
some recent estimates show a worst-case
scenario in which some 25 million people
could be neither with any sisters by the
end of this year
we hope this scenario does not
materialize but we are obliged to plan
for it
and we are expanding our cash assistance
distributing 100 million per month
reaching now 1.3 million people
by may
and covering 2 million by august
but this will be done in very close
coordination with the ukrainian
government
this is not a typical humanitarian u.n
operation
in a country in a developing country
with lots of problems of governance and
lots of difficulties the ukraine is a
country with a government and with a
system of support with citizens and so
the role of the uan is not to replace
that government is to support the
government
in the government section to support the
people of ukraine
our food aid has reached 2.3 million
people
but we want to help 4 million by may and
6 million by june and the plans will be
implemented
and with more than 12 million ukrainians
who fled their homes we are supporting
host countries that have generously
received over 5 million refugees
but more important
we are increasing our capacity to meet
the needs of 7.7 million that have been
displaced inside the country
based on a recent survey by the
international organization of migration
the world house organization is leaving
medical supplies for trauma and
emergency care for more than seven
million people
and they are also stepping up our vital
efforts to extend urgent health care
emergency shelter water and sanitation
and to protect children and gender based
violence
all in very close contact and very close
coordination with the ukrainian
government
and we are also advancing the work of
accountability and justice by monitoring
and reporting on human rights violations
wherever they are detected
ladies and gentlemen of the press
all this work is essential
but it doesn't address the root cause of
all this woman's suffering
the war itself
this war must end
and peace must be established in line
with the charter of united nations and
international law
many leaders have made many good efforts
to stop the fighting
but these efforts so far have not
succeeded
and i'm here to say to you mr president
and to the people of ukraine
we will not give up
as we keep pushing for a full-scale
ceasefire we'll also keep striving for
immediate practical steps to save lives
and reduce human suffering
effective humanitarian corridors local
cessations of hostilities safe passage
for civilian and supply routes
today
the people of mario paul
is in are in spirit needs for just such
an approach
mario paul is a crisis within a crisis
thousands of civilians with life-saving
assistance
many are elderly in need of medical care
or have limited mobility
they need an escape route out of the
apocalypse
during my visit to moscow
president putin agreed in principle to
the involvement of the united nations
and the international committee for the
red cross
in the evacuation of civilians from the
us hostile plant in maripo
today president zolensky and i had the
opportunity to address this issue
and as we speak
there are intense discussions to move
forward on this proposal to make it a
reality
finally let me say that in many ways we
are at ground zero for the world we need
to build
a world of respect for international law
duan charter and the power of
multilateralism a world that protects
civilians a world that advances human
rights
a world where leaders live up to the
values that they have promised to uphold
that too is a struggle
but it is one that we must win
for the sake of every country community
and person around the world thank you